[Music]
who's coming with me
in the movie Jerry Maguire Tom Cruise
plays a powerful sports agent who puts
his livelihood and reputation on the
line by leaving the company he helped
build in order to pursue a more
fulfilling career path while that may
seem like Hollywood going out on a limb
a little bit more and more Americans are
attempting something kind of similar
leaving behind stable but time-consuming
jobs in hopes of finding a better
work-life balance CBS News business
analyst Jill Schlesinger out with a new
book on how you can make that change it
is called the Great money reset change
your work change your wealth change your
life and she's here to impart some of
that wisdom with us this morning good
morning good morning that was Michelle
Jill I love it I love the idea so the
you basically say the main theme it's
not that it's Financial advice it's
rethinking our lives so explain that
first of all well you know this happens
often when you have a big life event a
birth a death divorce these things come
up but it was amid the pandemic that I
was just inundated with questions on my
podcast on my radio show after appearing
here and people saying I'm just really
feeling out of sorts I feel like not
just my work life balance is out of
whack but more like is this the way I
want to live and how can I use my money
or how can I use my options in a better
way what is the vehicle to get to the
next place essentially how can I reset
you got a little personal here
just a little bit tell us about what
your friend told you in that little pink
notebook adage so uh so here's the pink
notebook just want to show it to you so
I have a very dear friend Maureen who
worked at bet very great colleague and
friend and when I was going through a
personal transition I was an investment
advisor a money manager and I wanted to
go into media very successful one yeah
thanks man uh and uh you know it was
interesting that I was really feeling a
little down about that part of my life
and I said I said to Maureen can I you
think I can do this media thing full
time because you need a pink notebook
I'm like What's the pink notebook she
goes well you get a pink binder you have
the different sections and she says
here's the hard part for most people you
can do it easily it's the money part but
everything else you're going to
interview people maybe you were a guest
with Jeff glor once maybe Michelle
Miller interviewed you you're going to
talk to all these people you're going to
fill up your notes and you're going to
contemplate what would it look like to
have this life in another career and it
was in really important I mean look the
numbers are incredibly important and
we'll talk about that but it's the idea
of where are you going what are you
trying to get to the Jeff Gore interview
10 years ago may have pushed things over
the top yeah I don't know but I'm just
saying um you you write in times of
transition there is one thing that can
fight mounting anxiety better than a
therapist or a drink what is it cash and
what I mean by that is that for a lot of
people having an extra large safety net
amid a trans position is incredibly
important and I mean cash in a liquid
accessible account a bank account like a
savings account a checking account a
money market a short-term CD or a
Government Bond why is this so important
you know you guys always hear me say six
to 12 months of emergency reserves of
your expenses that's what you need you
need even more when you're making a
transition because as you feel anxiety
it's absolutely going to help you get
through that anxiety real quick five
steps to make the financial reset and I
mean real quick okay number one figure
out your resources your assets your
income number two your liabilities your
debt number three consider your housing
Situation Number Four you need to really
track your spending and finally make
sure you are cool with all the
obligations you've made to your family
members because your reset is impacting
a number of people in your life now you
can do it you say the big question is
should you how do you distinguish I
think that a lot of people go through
this process and no matter what the
outcome is you're going to feel more in
control but many many people will say I
look at this I look at the best case I
look at the worst case I look at the
middle case and you know what I'm
actually okay where I am I'm pretty good
and staying put is absolutely fine it's
just going through the process will
actually make you feel better about
where you are Jill thank you very much
congratulations on the book and thank
you thank you for the signed copies here
thank you Jill's book The Great money
reset is available in bookstores now